for me that these are really exciting
when we started I happy a lot of people
said you know you can't go to poor
communities in sub-saharan African get
this type of research done should be
done close to academic centers in the
West and and you know for me we've
proven the opposite the the level of
engagement on the ground and then the
quality of work we've recently had our
laboratories in Africa have been you
know not only validated but accredited
and you know they've done fabulously so
the work there is done better than it is
or at least as good as in anywhere else
in the world and so seeing a team like
that come together the pride that exists
them the hard work and the reason they
perform so well is because they're in it
for I mean they're living in their
community and seeing it they all have
stories to tell and so that to me is has
been my you know in a sense proudest
moment but let me give you another
example of something that was
interesting we recently began to work
with a group of male sex workers in East
Africa now when I lived in Uganda it was
said that homosexuality in Africa was
almost unheard of and it is very rare
it's not a large it's not something
that's well condoned and all of that so
here was a group of sex workers who had
been doing it I've been operating there
and to see them engaged in wanting to
get involved in this and having them
celebrate with each other and the
ability even to be open about it and
talk about it and to even see that the
other investigators in the setting to
see them and feel uncomfortable you know
in a setting because they hadn't the
investigators had dealt with their own
concerns about it but to see that kind
of bonding and sharing listen supported
we certainly have to be extremely
careful you know on discussing these
things and talking about them and and
you know I myself was early on one of my
hardest experiences was when I first
went to cuss and Sarah which is the
place where age was first documented on
the African continent where the slim
disease him on the way down there we
were ambushed and the car behind us
somebody was shot in the head and being
the only Doctor I had to provide medical
care and spend the night sleeping in the
clinic where the first cases were
diagnosed not knowing whether these guys
were going to come back and try to get
us and eventually sending for help in a
in a in a canoe getting soldiers to come
and help escort us out so the answer is
I've certainly been in situations that
it's been pretty trying but you know the
other side of it is that when you deal
with you know your investigators your
people everybody has a story when you're
there you spend time with them they'll
tell you about their brothers and
sisters and others who have died from
this disease and and to watch the the
amazing dedication that occurs by having
that incredible connection you ask
people why are you doing this why are
you so and and they say I don't want my
child to grow up in the fear in this
situation and so amazing
member